[Music]  you told me the story of the war when  the ground shook in the sky burn  of the ones that survived who will woke  to a different world where the powerful  right but that's not the way it has to  be  when I found you you're very human brain  was miraculously intact it's the  loneliest feeling not to know who you  are in time you'll remember  [Music]  Oh  Elita is doing here it's a harsh world  down here you got to be willing to do  what it takes  [Music]  Mika's she's the last of a kind  she contains technology that have been  lost for 300 years let me show you  something  [Music]  this body I feel a connection to it I  can't explain you know more about me  than you're saying oh he does some  things have better left forgotten and  I'll find out for myself  she's threatening the natural order  thing I need you to destroy her leader  they will come for you  I'll have them head on  tonight is not again  [Music]  [Music]  I'm sir  [Music]